not going to let parents come into
schools and actually take books out make
their own decision I don't think parents
should be telling schools what they
should teach well remember that moment
right judge that's the moment perhaps
when Democrats lost the Virginia
governorship thanks to the arrogance
their arrogance on education well it
looks like they haven't learned much
since then Democratic Congressman Eric
swalwell thinks it's stupid for
Republicans to put parents back in
charge of their kids learning swallow
tweeted the following please tell me
what I'm missing here what are we doing
next putting patients in charge of their
own surgeries clients in charge of their
own trials when did we stop trusting
experts this is so stupid I guess Eric
wasn't paying attention on Tuesday a
pro-parent group telling Fox quote
parents are fired up and they're winning
even in blue States conservatives
flipped school boards in Michigan and
Maryland and more than 40 candidates
backed by parentals rights groups
notched wins in Minnesota a judge let's
start with you you what is swallow well
missing
um you know what did he say when we
stopped listening to what was it
experts yeah I'll tell you when when
fauci showed up that's when we stopped
listening to experts
um you know the truth is that the
parents are
um that they are the ones who decide
where they want to send their children
to school what they want them to learn
you can send them to a Catholic School a
Lutheran School a charter school a
Jewish school a public school I mean you
can move your residents to put them in a
different school I mean we make these
decisions based upon what we want our
children to learn when we will move
because we don't like the way the
teachers are are teaching or or treating
our kids so the idea that they are in
local parentis and they are the ones who
are going to decide what our kids learn
is absurd because we pay taxes that pay
them and pay for the schools and they're
not going to tell any parent and I don't
care if you're in a blues state or a red
State we saw it in this election parents
are outraged it's like Mama Bear came
out and said don't you play around with
my Cubs and that's exactly but it's all
about parents being fired up and it is
something that I think is going to cut
into the indoctrination that our kids
have been learning that our kids who are
now the heads of Corporations have
learned for for decades that we didn't
know about and now we're suffering from
that's going to stop now Harold I'm
going to quote you you stop me if you
think I'm being unfair as I ask this
question to Dana oh Harold has said in
the course of this show today that he
does trust polling I think that's a fair
skepticism to hold also said that he
hopes the left doesn't see that they are
emboldened by the outcome of these
midterm elections do you think you
ignore these parental rights these
issues if you're the left at your own
Peril well so I uh they won't because
there's a couple of things on education
they might try I mean the the teachers
unions are very powerful but they know
now I've been waiting for some results
in California I think a lot of those
school boards are going to flip as well
to Republicans there is also going to be
hearings and the reason I do think that
they're paying attention a little bit is
we haven't talked about it in this show
and it's a slightly different subject
but the White House did tell the head of
the Customs and Border Patrol guy that
what's his name they said you need to
resign or you'll be fired he's refusing
to resign and they're going to fire him
but I thought the Border was so secure
what's his name
Chris Magnus okay he was around remember
he was falling asleep falling asleep in
the meetings and everything treating the
staff terribly but they told us for
months that everything was fine
um and then they're firing him they said
everything was okay with education it's
clearly not and the test scores that
came out proved that the last thing I
would say is the Biden Administration
knew that the student loan bailout was
unconstitutional they did it anyway it
worked for them you had people were like
great okay that we can be for Biden this
is great remember AOC praised him up one
side and down the other it's going to
turn out to be unconstitutional and the
Supreme Court is going to push back so
basically what the bite Administration
did is they LED people along to believe
something even though they knew it was
unconstitutional that they're never
going to get it just like they did with
the eviction moratorium
Greg yeah um I just uh before I get into
my main points I just want to quote what
Harold had said to me in the Green Room
which is he supported well well because
in Harold's words I hate children so
much they make me sick you like his
quoting you here yeah uh but um
but this is why the the Republicans have
to further cement themselves as the
parents party right and let the Dems be
the party of the government government
interference between mother and father
and child let them defend activists who
push gender ideology in preschool let
them be against school choice and
in-person learning Republicans should be
the pro family party because it's
working when then left calls you racist
what do you call them groomers even if
it ain't true because the racist stuff
ain't true either and then finally I do
want to point out that like we have to
remind everybody that the teachers
unions you know they are they may be the
most systemically racist organization
simply by being against choice because
that really hurts hurts minorities when
it comes to having a competent education
that sets him up for Life Harold is this
an issue where you hope the left doesn't
feel affirmed or emboldened in the wake
of the midterms
um from the standpoint of the the
statement that Mr swalwell made I just I
disagree with that parents have to be
involved and I but also think we have to
let Educators do their job as well and
there needs to be a healthy tension and
a healthy relationship tension meaning
in a constructive way between parents
and teachers Republicans need to take a
message also that all this stuff they
talked about with education didn't seem
to resonate either at least with a
majority of the country you look at
Florida it did but in Michigan uh the
DeVos family they they competed in over
almost 200 School Board seats they only
won 30. that doesn't mean to say that
everything that they're for that I'm
against but clearly they didn't convince
a number of people in Michigan that the
states of count yes it is California
Michigan Idaho Colorado Minnesota all
had referendums and about to increase
spending on public education now these
are states that some are conservative
some are liberal clearly I don't know
all the the characteristics of how those
referendums went how they campaigned for
them but they but they passed voters
don't want culture wars in their
classrooms they don't want book bands I
don't think they want dishonest teaching
and they still really don't want their
kids to be taught that they're bad be
they black white or Hispanic there's a
way to do this I think Greg you make a
point about I'm going to go as far as is
the racist point about teachers units
but I do think those who who purport to
be advocates for kids and particularly
black and brown kids in this country
we're failing them and have failed them
long before covet uh the quality of
Education that a lot of these kids were
were having shown them was not the
quality should say did not meet the
standard it would need for them to get
into college to get into vocational
school for that matter to be the kind of
contributing citizens that we want
absolutely hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else